et on part à présent russie ou locaux
vides 19 continue sa propagation ou
flambée épidémique qui inquiète les
autorités ignorent encore un nouveau
record de quatre contamination était à
enregistrer obligeons moscou a multiplié
les mesures de freinage le point sur la
situation avec notre correspondante
verhaeghe hochmann la période chômée a
officiellement commencé le 30 octobre
partout en russie selon le décret de
vladimir poutine est les autorités
russes essaie de freiner l'envolée des
chiffres de contamination et de décès le
ministre russe de la santé michael moore
est chaud qui a été détaché par le
président dans les régions russes où la
situation est la plus tendue affirme que
les mesures restrictives introduites la
semaine dernière dans certaines régions
ont déjà un effet je vous propose
d'écouter nous constatons dans tout le
pays que le nombre de personnes venant
se faire vacciner a presque quadruplé au
cours des 10 derniers jours nous avons
déjà remarqué que le taux de morbidité a
diminué dans les régions où les mesures
restrictives avaient été introduites
notamment les qr codes c'est un bon
résultat aujourd'hui nous devons
certainement travailler sur la
prévention de la propagation du virus le
pays est en proie à une quatrième vague
du coc vide 19 qui dépasse largement les
chiffres des vagues précédentes en
nouveau record de contamination a été
notamment enregistrées ces dernières 24
heures plus de 40 mille nouveaux cas de
coronavirus le nombre de décès
quotidiens dépasse 1000 personnes chaque
jour depuis déjà deux semaines